[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قال قيادي في المعارضه
السوريه المسلحه ان العمليه العسكريه درع
الفرات التي تشارك فيها القوات التركيه
ستسهم في انشاء منطقه امنه داخل سوريا
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي الترتيبات المتوقعه لاقامه
مثل هذه المنطقه في سياق العمليه التي
تشارك فيها القوات
التركيه وكيف سينعكس ذلك على الوضع
الميداني داخل سوريا في ضوء مواقف الاطراف
الفاعله الاخرى في
الصراع المنطقه الامنه داخل سوريا فكره
تطرحها انقره منذ نحو اربع بع سنوات
للسيطره على منطقه الحدود السوريه معها
وحمايه النازحين دون ان تجد اذانا صاغيه
لدى الغرب وخاصه واشنطن الان وبعد انطلاق
العمليه العسكريه التركيه شمالي سوريا عاد
الحديث مجددا عن اقامه هذه المنطقه من
خلال تصريحات لقيادي في المعارضه السوريه
المسلحه اكد فيها ان عمليه درع الفرات
ستسهم في اقامه هذه المنطقه وكذلك وزير
الخارجيه التركي الذي قال ان ذلك يجب ان
يتم بالتعاون مع حلفاء انقره وبدعم جوي من
التحالف تقرير مريم
ابيش ما بعد معركه جرابلس التي طرد منها
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وقطع الطريق على
القوات الكرديه القادم هو منطقه امنه
منطقه لطالما سعت انقره الى اقامتها
واختلفت بشانها مع حلفائها وحلفاء خصومها
اليوم تغيرت مواقف كثيره وحتى التحالفات
وتتحقق ص
تجعل المرفوض مقبولا على
ماد اذا كنا سنقيم منطقه امنه يجب ان نقوم
بذلك مع حلفائنا وبدعم جوي من قوات
التحالف الدوليه وبعد ذلك يمكن ان يعود
السكان الذين اجبرتهم القوات الكرديه
وداعش على ترك مساكنهم اذا كانوا يرغبون
في ذلك لاننا لن نجبرهم على العوده فهم
بالاساس هربوا من المنطقه بسبب الحرب
والمنظمات
الارهابيه سبق هذا التصريح قيادي في
المعارضه السوريه الذي قال ان قوات درع
الفرات التي تشارك فيها القوات التركيه
ستسهم في انشاء منطقه امنه داخل سوريا
يضيف القيادي ان المنطقه ستكون بطول 70
كيلومترا وبعمق 20 كيلومترا كان الحديث في
السابق عن عمق
35 كيلومترا يتزامن ذلك مع تاكيد اكثر من
مصدر ومسؤول انسحاب القوات الكرديه الى
منطقه شرق نهر الفرات يشار الا ان جرابلس
تقع في الضفه الغربيه للنهر وكانت انقره
حددت منذ فتره نهر الفرات خطا احمرا ينبغي
على المسلحين الاكراد تجاوزه وفق اخر
الاخبار ارسل الجيش التركي تعزيزات اضافيه
الى المنطقه الحدوديه المقابله لمدينه
جرابلس لم تكن انقره تنظر بعين الرضا
لتقدم القوات الكرديه المدعومه من
الولايات المتحده بعد سيطرتها على منبج
وحديثها عن الوصول الى جرابلس والباب
تحركها السريع الذي سبق بساعات وصول نائب
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى انقره كان
يحمل اكثر من رساله وطرح اكثر من تساؤل هل
ثم صفقه امريكيه تركيه جعلت واشنطن تضغط
على الاكراد للانسحاب من غرب الفرات وتدعم
الاتراك في عمليتهم العسكريه من المستفيد
الاكبر من هذه التطورات انقر تمضي في قطع
الطريق امام الاكراد وتقول ان المنطقه
الامنه ستمنع تمزيق سوريا ما يهم واشنطن
هو القضاء على تنظيم الدوله وغيره من
التنظيمات التي تسميها ارهابيه هل ثمت
خيارات اخرى امام الاكراد بعد ضغوط واشنطن
وتغير سياسه موسكو منذ لقاء اردوغان
ببوتين المنطقه الامنه التي تريدها تركيا
هل ستكون امنه لها فقط ام لغيرها ايضا
نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من باريس منظر
ماخوس المتحدث باسم الهيئه العليا
للمفاوضات في المعارضه السوريه وسفير
الاتلاف السوري المعارض في باريس من
اسطنبول جينز تومار استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في معهد دراسات الشرق الاوسط ومن
موسكو فيت شلاف ماتوزوف الدبلوماسي الروسي
السابق لو بدانا بالسيد منظر ماخوس هل
لديكم اي تصور ولو اولي عن احتمال اقامه
منطقه امنه في شمال
سوريا نعم اخي محمد كما نعرف جميعا هذا
الموضوع قديم متجدد وقد طرح كما ورد في
تقريركم منذ حوالي اربعه سنوات وفي تلك
المرحله كنا نعتقد على انه مشروع واقعي
وكنا نراهن على انه قد يشكل خرق حقيقي في
المساله السوريه وقد كان من الممكن ان
يغير المساله برمتها منذ تلك اللحظه تماما
كما لو تم التعامل مع الملف الكيميائي بعد
استعمالها على نطاق واسع في الغوطه سنه
2013 هذين الملفين هم الملفين الوحيدين
الذين يمكن ان يحدثوا خرق شامل ويغير يقلب
المعادله السوريه بمتع هذا الموضوع لم
يحدث اليوم مطروح من من
جديد للوهله الاولى قد يبدو حلم خاصه اذا
طرح بنفس الاطار الذي كان مطروح فيه سابقا
لان في اول المشروع كان مطروح شريط على
طول الحدود الطويله السوريه التركيه والتي
تمتد او تزيد عن 900 م وكان ايضا مطروح
بعمق كان لم يكن هناك عمق محدد بين 20 الى
35 م بغض النظر عن هذه الفرص في تلك
اللحظه والتي اثبتت التجربه على انها لم
تكن واقعيه بالمناسبه نحن كمعارض كانت تلك
الايام هي
ايام الائتلاف الوطني السوري الذي كان هو
في الذروه في تلك المرحله وكنا نقوم
بعمليه تسويق غير مسبوقه وحتى هنا في
باريس لقد اقمنا عده مؤتمرات صحفيه من اجل
تسويق هذا المشروع وحتى اضطررنا الى تمويل
ذاتي كما يقال من اجل ايضا ان نخلق ضغط
اعلامي على المجتمع الدولي وخاصه على
اللاعبين الاقليميين من
اجل الوصول الى مثل هذا المشروع اليوم كان
كما نعرف الموقف الامريكي يترا ال الان
مثل ما ذكرت سيد مقوس مثل ما ذكرت الان
الموضوع يطرح من جديد ولكن هل هل تركيا
تعتزم
فعلا مثل هذا الامر نسال ضيفنا من من
اسطنبول سيد جنكس تومار اقامه منطقه امنه
في شمال سوريا على الحدود مع مع تركيا هل
تعتقد بانها الان الفكره ستجد طريقها من
جديد نحو
تنفيذ
ا تركيا طبعا من البدايه من اربع سنوات
كما تفضل الاستاذ في باريس كانت تريد هذا
ا ولكن بسبب
ال المشكله الان تغيير سياسه تركيه اتجاه
سوريا وكما تحالف روسيا ايران
تركيا وايضا اظن امريكا في هذه النقطه
الان انشاء المنطقه الامنه اكثر واقعيا في
هذه
المنطقه وخاصه طبعا تركيا لها دور كبير في
سوريا وفي هدود السوريه
الان اذا يكون هنا اذا تكون هناك منطقه
الامنه هنا يعني تركيا تستفيد اكثر بسبب
اللاجئين ايضا بسبب السياسه التركيه تجاه
الاكراد لان تركيا لا تريد
هناك الحزام الكردي وايضا لا تريد داعش
اظن هذه السياسه
الان المنطقه الامنه اكثر واقعيا وهذا
ممكن بالنسبه ل سيد تمار ممكن سيد تمار
ولكن لا احد من المسؤولين الاتراك لا
الرئيس ولا المسؤول الكبار تحدث بشكل واضح
وصريح عن هذا الهدف ك كتتويج ربما للعمليه
العسكريه
الحاليه اظن الان طبعا نحن الان في بدايه
بدايه التحركات طبعا بعد جرابلس اظن تركيا
والجيش
الحر سينزل الى الجنوب تقريبا حتى ممكن
الباب
وتركيا اظن تتكلم مع روسيا وايران
وروسيا
هذه هذا المشروع ولكن لا تريد الان الان
تعلن يعني قبل ان تتفق مع حلفاء لانه
اذا لا يوجد هناك الاتفاق بين تركيا
وروسيا وامريكا هذا صعب جدا ان تقيم
المنطقه امنه هناك بسبب الغارات الجويه
نعم تحدثت عن عن روسيا بالطبع روسيا الان
تعيش مرحله جديده سيد ماتوزوف في علاقاتها
مع مع تركيا تركيا ايضا لها صفحه جديده مع
ايران هل تعتقد بان موسكو ربما قد تنظر
الى موضوع المنطقه الامنه في شمال سوريا
بشكل مختلف هذه المره نتيجه العلاقات
الجديده مع
انقره مع زميلي
في تركيا الذي يقول ان هذا امر ممكن
والواقعي ب شرط ان هذا
الاقتراح يطبق بتعاون مع بين سلطه تركيه
سلطه سوريه ايران وروسيا لان روسيا
متواجده على بعد عده عشرات كيلومترات عن
حدود مع تركيا مع قاعده الحميمين ولا شك
ان هذا مشكله اليوم اوسع من القرار
التحالف تحت الرئاسه الامريكيه ونحن سمعنا
اكثر من مره انه تركيا تعيد نظرها في في
سياستها في موقفها من ملاف السوري وفي
اثار هذه السياسه الجديده انا لا استسن ان
الاطراف المذكوره تتوصل الى اي حال اي
اساس اساس واقفل اطلاق النار
وقف واعلان الهدنه وهذا الاساس يمكن ان
يعلنوا ليست من طرف واحد من تركيا او من
امريكا ان من كل اطراف متورط في هذه
المعارك الدمويه يعلن بصوت واحد ان هذا
واقف الطلاق نار والهدنه نعم ه هذا بشكل
هذا بشكل عام سيد ماتوزوف لكن اذا بقينا
في الحدث الان المتعلق بالعمليه العسكريه
الجاريه حاليه في شمال سوريا البعض يقول
بانه لولا علاقات انقره الجيده الان مع
روسيا ربما لما فعلتها تركيا طالما ان
العلاقات جيده هل تعتقد بان يمكن لانقره
ان تقنع روسيا هذه المره بان امكانيه
اقامه هذه المنطقه جيد حتى لمصلحه التوصل
الى تسويه
سياسيه انا اعتبر ان فكره منطقه الامنه
التي نحن سمينا اربع سنوات ما كانت ممكنه
بسبب واحد ان الروسيا كانت السلطه السوريه
كانت ضد
اي تداخل في شؤون الداخليه لسوريا
وصلاحيات وسياده الدوله كان في اولويات
اما اليوم عندما دخلت جيش التركي الى
اراضي سوريه وورع الجيش التركي هناك جيش
سوري حر وهذا امر الواقع الاجي وافق بلا
اي
كلام سوريا روسيا لان انا ما سمعته
المعارضه قويه لتدخل العسكري التركي لا من
دمشق ولا في موسكو كانت هناك التمنيات ان
يرافق هذا التدخل موافقه السلطه السوريه
على اي وجود العسكري في ارض سوريه ولكن لا
كانت احتجاج القوي بسبب واحد انه لا شك ان
تدخل التركي الذي لعب دورا ايجابيا لان
منعت تقسيم الدوله السوريه الخطر
امتداد الكردي من منبج الى بحر الابيض
المتوسط والحزام هذا بين تركيا وسوريا
كانت واضح تماما يتبلور وكان خاطر اعلان
الدوله
المستقله
المراق ك نعم نظرا لكل هذه المخاوف التي
تتحدث عنها الان سيد ماتوزوف هل هذا الامر
سيد منظر
ماخوس يعاد طرحه من جديد وبالتالي لن تظفر
المعارضه السوريه بهذه المنطقه التي
تتمناها منذ
سنوات نعم هذا بيت القصيد في النهايه فعلا
نحن تكلمنا عن تجربه السابقه لكن اصبح ذلك
جزء من الماضي اليوم الصوره الجديده
اللوحه الجديده المطروحه على الارض تختلف
جذريا بالحقيقه انا تقديري اكثر من ذلك
على ان الانخراط الروسي عندما دخلوا منذ
اكثر من عام
في الحرب السوريه بشكل مباشر وغير مسبوق
كان احد اهدافه الاساسيه لكي لا اقون كل
اهداف هو منع قيام المنطقه العازله التي
كانت مطروحه في ذلك الوقت والتي كما كنت
اريد ان اقول انها لم تحدث بسبب التردد
الامريكي في ذلك الوعد اي قبل ان يحدث
الانخراط الروسي المباشر العارض كانوا
يقولون احيانا على انها مكلفه جدا اما في
النقاشات التي كانت تحدث في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه وفي وزاره الخارجيه كانت تقول
انه سوف يكون مغامره كبيره واننا نخاطر
بالانزلاق مره اخرى في سوريا هذه المره
بعد تجربه العراق وافغانستان
وقد ادى فعلا الانخراط الروسي ووجود روسيا
بهذا الزخم الذي نعرفه على الارض لان تصبح
هذه المن هذه الفكره فكره المناطق العازله
والمحميه او ربما ممنوعه الطيران من
ذكريات الماضي اليوم انا كنت الحقيقه
انتظر اللي كي اسمع زميلي السيد ب سلاف
ماتوزوف من موسكو على الرغم من تقدير
الاول لكن كنت اريد ان اعرف هل فعلا هناك
نوع من المقاربه الروسيه وكما تكلم
وينسجم تماما مع تصوري وهو انه من الصعب
تماما ان يحدث هو طرح نوع من السيناريو
مستحيل التحقيق ان قال بشرط ان يكون هناك
توافق بين الروسيا وايران والنظام السوري
وغيره هذا مستحيل تماما لانه برغم كل
التحولات التي حدثت بعد اعاده التموضع
الروسي التركي وهو باصله وبجذي
وباهم ته هو ذو بعد اقتصادي بالدرجه
الاولى لان هناك مصالح مشتركه ومتبادل
وعلى نفس الدرجه للطرفين كل من الطرفين
كان يحلم ان يبادر الطرف الاخر حدث ذلك
ولكن لا يزال من وجهه نظري ياخذ ابعاد
اقتصاديه مع بعض الابعاد السياسيه التي لن
تكون كبيره بسبب ان التوازن المصالح
للطرفين لن يؤدي الى ثمن سياسي
كبير ولهذا سي ولهذا سيد موس ولهذا ربما
ولهذا سيد مخوص يعني بعد اذنك ولهذا طرح
موضوع المنطقه الامنه او المنطقه العازله
الان ما زالت كاحتمال
بعيد المدى او متوسط المدى هذا لا احد
يستطيع ان ان يجزم به لكن على كل سنحاول
بعد الفاصل ان نتطرق لاي تغيير يمكن ان
يحدثه مثل هذا التطور سواء على الملف
السوري سياسيا او حتى عسكريا لنا عوده بعد
فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلنا معكم في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الحديث مجددا عن
امكانيه اقامه منطقه عازله في شمال سوريا
على الحدود مع تركيا وهو الحديث الذي بدا
يعود مجددا سيد جنكس توار على افتراض ان
انقره استطاعت ان تفرض هذه المنطقه سواء
بتفاهمات مع الدول المعنيه او حتى بامر
واقع وهذا ما ربما يستبعده البعض ما الذي
يمكن ان يتغير في المنطقه كلها بسبب هذا
التطور
اي طبعا في ال يعني بعد المحاوله الفاشله
بعد المحاوله الانقلاب في تركيا تغيرت
اشياء كثيرا
وهناك المشاكل كثيره في داخل تركيا سواء
حزب الامال الكردستاني وداعش وايضا
الجماعات فت الله كلان وبسبب هذه المشاكل
طبعا تركيه تنازلت نوعا ما من عن بعض
سياستها تجاه سوريا وهنا الان طبعا داعش
لكل واحد من امريكا روسيا وسوريا
وايران يعني ما في احد في المنطقه يحب
الداعش وفي هذه المنطقه
الان الداعش موجود هذه المنظمه
وعندما
تنزل الجيش الحر وال القوات
التركيه اتجاه سوريا الجنوب يعني الى
منطقه الباب منب ويعني اظن ستكون هناك
منطقه نوعا ما
ازله ومتحرره من داعش وبعد ذلك يعني هذا
الشيء اظنه واقعي وتركيا تحاول ان تتفاهم
مع روسيا وامريكا في هذه النقطه كما تفضل
الاستاذ في في روسيا هناك شيء طبعا
روسيا تستطيع ان تضغط على ايران
وسوريا ولها يعني تاثير كبير في المنطقه
وتستطيع
ان تناقش مع سوريا هذه النقطه
حتى تغير تركيا سياسته تجاه نظام الاسد
حتى تبقى هناك الفتره يعني
مازالت هل هل هذه المنطقه نعم يعني هل
المنطقه العازله او الامنه هي فعلا في في
صميم الحسابات التركيه لان مثلا على سبيل
المثال عندما نطالع صحيفه الصباح التركيه
تحدد العمليه التركيه الجاريه حاليا باربع
اهداف تقول تطهير المنطقه من داعش تخريب
لعبه الممر الكردي ثالثا دحر قوات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه ورابعا الحيلوله دون
موجه هجره جديده هل هل فعلا تركيا في
حسابها هذه المنطقه ربما اشارت اليها هكذا
دون ان تعمل عليها بشكل
جدي طبعا كما تعرفون هذه الجريده و لها
اعراء وقريبه من الحكومه تركيه وهذه
الاراء طبعا الاراء حكومه التركيه تقريبا
وتركيا الان تحاول ان
تقنع روسيا وامريكا اظن الان بالنسبه
لامريكا هذه ليست مشكله
كبيره
ولكن هناك نظام بشار الاسد
وروسيا موجوده يجب ان تقنع تركيا روسيا
وتقنع روسيا نظام الاسد هل هل هذا وارد ه
هذه المعادله هذه المعادله الترك نعم هذه
المعادله الروسيه السوريه التركيه
المتعدده سيد ماتوزوف هل هل تعتقد بان هذا
امر ممكن ان ان ان تبحث واشنطن وموسكو هذا
الامر بالتنسيق مع تركيا وقد يتم فعلا
انشاء مثل هذه
المنطقه وبتنسيق مع السلطه السوريه كذلك
اضيفه انا اعتبر هذا ممكن جدا واكثر من
هذا اذا نحن الان نناقش موضوع المنطقه
الامنه من زاويه الاستمرار الحرب في
الداخل سوريا هذا شيئا واذا نحن ننتقل
مركز البحث الى مؤتمر جنيف
وتطبيق المبادئ التي تفق عليه امريكا
وروسيا في فيين وفي اطار الحل والحوار
السياسي سوري سوري في جنيف اي مسائل
مرتبطه مع هدنه مع وقف الاطلاق النار وهذا
سيكون منطقه الامنه هذا يسمح المهاجرين ان
يرجع الى بيوتهم ان يوقف القتال اختيال
وعلى هذا الاساس على اساس تشجيع المفاوضات
في جنيف انا اعتبر هنا مفتاح لتوصل الى
الهدف ولكن اي نيه ان يسيطروا ان يامروا
ان هذا المنطقه الامنه ممنوع عليكم طيران
ممنوع عليكم التحركات العسكريه هذا لا
يمشي فقط في اطار الحل السياسي الشامل
واتفاق بين معارضه وسلطه سوريه في بنود
الاساسيه في جنيف وفي هذا المطرح في هذا
الاطار يمكن ان يتواصل الى اي حلول بما
فيها اعلان المنطقه الامنه منطقه خاليه من
من السلاح من باي شكل من الاشكال اذا بهذا
المعنى سيد منظر ماخوس يعني القضيه مطوله
مطوله مثل ما مثل ما يقال باللهجه العاميه
اذا دخلنا في دوامه التفاصيل المتعلقه
بالملف السوري يصبح الحديث عن منطقه امنه
ربما اقرب الى التمني وليس الى
الواقع نعم انا موافق على هذه وجهه النظر
تماما مع احترامي طبعا مره اخرى
للمقاربة بشرط ان يكون النظام السوري جزء
من هذه العمليه انا لا اعتقد ان النظام
السوري سوف يكون جزء ولا ايران وحتى
الروسيا هي التي تحسم الموضوع في النهايه
لكن حتى انا ابحث الموضوع من وجهه النظر
الروسيه البحثه كلاعب اساسي اليوم هي في
سوريا وخاصه اليوم وضع روسيا غير وضع
روسيا عندما دخلت في البدايه وكانت فقط في
قاعده حميمين التي كانت في مراحلها الاولى
اليوم اليوم قاعده حميمين هي العنصر
الاكبر في كل سياسه ليس في سوريا وانما في
الشرق الاوسط انا برايي الروس هذه المره
جاؤوا لكي لا يخرجوا على الاطلاق ولكي لا
يتم فرض اي حل لا يحقق مصالحهم
الاستراتيجيه وفي مقدمتها خوفهم من وصول
الجماعات التي يسمونها متطرفه الى اراضيهم
من هذا بهذا الافق لا يزال مصلحتهم هي هي
ولن يذهب بعيدا في هذه المساله انا لست
مقتنع تماما هل ه تؤدي
الى بالتوازي مع تقدم سياسي في جنيف انا
لا اجد ان هناك ارتباط مباشر بين هتين
المسالتين لان سي سيد مخوص باختصار شديد
هل تعتقد بان تركيا يمكن ان تصل الى حد
فرضها كامر واقع دون تفاهمات سياسيه مع
الاطراف التي اشرنا
اليها لا اعتقد على الاطلاق على الاطلاق
لانه حتى اذا اخذناها من منصور العلاقات
الروسيه التركيه اذا لم تكن هناك موافقه
روسيه فهذا يهدد ايضا كل هذه العلاقات
والتي هي مره اخرى اقول استراتيجيه وبالغت
الاهميه لكل الطرفين و والتركيه ايضا في
المقدمه من هذه المساله لا اعتقد ان الطرف
ما يستطيع ان يفرضها اما بالمناسبه
التقييم النهائي لهذه المساله يتعلق ما هو
شكل هذه المنطقه الامنه هل هي فقط من اجل
ان تتيح فرصه للمهاجرين هل هي فقط من هل
يجب ان تكون مترافق بوقت نار شامل كما
تقدم السيد شكراك انا باعتقادي كل هذا غير
واقع ويحتاج الى المزيد من تدقيق شكرا لك
سييد منظر ماخوس من باريس شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من اسطنبول جنكس تومار وشكرا
لضيفنا من موسكو فاتسلاف ماتوزوف
دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ل